salles d'attentes vide des visiteurs qui
entrent au compte gouttes les policiers
de bourges n'ont pas le droit de grève
mais ils montrent leur mécontentement
aujourd'hui c'est pas les gilet jaune
s'est scellée giraud bleus en fait
finalement c'est ce qui se passe là on
va filtrer un petit peu l'accueil de
telle façon à ce que les jambes il
patiente cinq minutes ces cinq minutes
pour leur police c'est pas la fin du
monde
café croissants ce matin dans le hall
d'accueil du commissariat chacun déplore
raconte son ras-le-bol ses difficultés
au quotidien
on est sur le pont depuis plus de cinq
semaines tous nos collègues s'engager où
il ya des rappels décoller conte et
leurs congés de supprimer on a une
augmentation des heures supplémentaires
on est fatigué à sa faut rajouter plan
vigipirate le plan anti hold up
les collègues qui interviennent sur les
gilets jaunes qui sont pas dotés de
matériels individuels de protection pas
de jambes hier pas de casque individuel
les crs ont sans doute et
individuellement mais nous rend sécurité
publique on en a pas donc en fait on va
au casse pipe sans protection donc s'il
admissibles et à côté de ça nous on va
dans les chantiers contrôlés les
travailleurs qui sont en chantier quand
ils n'ont pas de casse qui sont
verbalisés alors donc faites faites ce
que je dis faites pas ce que je fais
quoi les policiers réclament du matériel
le paiement des 23 millions d'heures
supplémentaires accumulées un budget de
2 174 millions d'euros qu'ont fait
crédit à nos trains à notre patron si
une entreprise privée se comporter comme
ça aux prud'hommes à elle serait
condamnée et nous on dit rien et ça fait
des années que ça dure on dit rien ce
que ces heures elles ont pas été
cumulées en ian r côté rémunération même
constat les salaires sont bas et
n'augmente pas alors ici c'est le
salaire brut 1 vous voyez 1799 43 7e
échelon s'est à peu près 15 ans
d'ancienneté
en fait on paie un gardien de la paix
avec une technicité 1 catégorie v
d'administration avec des diplômes bien
moins cher que dans le privé finalement
et au risque de se faire tuer tous les
jours ce qui lui donne droit à un
week-end avec sa famille une fois toutes
les six semaines
quant aux 300 euros de primes accordées
cette nuit les policiers espèrent qu'il
s'agit bien d'un budget
supplémentaires pas d'un recyclage